this is the first official visit by U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken to
Turkey since he took office two years
ago he arrived here on Sunday nearly two
weeks after devastating earthquakes
shook Southern turkey and Northern Syria
Lincoln says Washington is ready to help
Ankara for as long as it takes stressing
the fact rebuilding in this region will
require a lot of time and effort NATO's
expansion is also on the agenda
Finland and Sweden have already taken
concrete steps to fulfill the
commitments they made under the
trilateral memorandum of agreement that
they signed with turkey on the margins
of the NATO Summit in Madrid we welcome
and appreciate those steps I think
they're quite significant the U.S Center
kit don't agree on every issue while
giving a green light for Finland to join
NATO Ankara believes Sweden needs to do
more chuke's air defense capability is
another issue for the NATO allies to
discuss especially after Ankara
purchased Russian missile systems in
we discussed the latest situation
regarding our F-16 request at the
meeting today the U.S Administration
strongly supports our plea we thank them
for this we hope they will make an
official notification to the U.S
Congress on this matter as soon as
possible and it is in the interest of
both parties to complete this process
promptly
is not in favor of conditional sales of
the f-16s and has asked for the return
of the 1.4 billion dollars Ankara paid
for the F-35 fighter jet program
turkia was unilaterally removed from it
turkish-american relations have been
strained for some time now but despite
this Washington's immediate relief
response to Ankara shows that your
relationship is still strong and that
NATO still needs to care however there
are still many issues to overcome
Americans support for ypg Kurdish
fighters in Syria is one of them Turkish
officials have designated the group as a
terrorist organization and say the U.S
cooperation is a great mistake while
Washington insists the ypg is crucial
for its fight against isil see Namco
solo Al Jazeera Ankara